we're going to begin in carolina where
cam newton the quarterback of the
panthers has been placed on injured
reserve more than seven weeks after
suffering
a foot injury well
aggravating the foot injury he suffered
it in the preseason he rushed himself
back for week one they had the short
week game against the tampa bay
buccaneers lost to the rams on the
opening sunday lost to the bucks and
then cam newton ended up out he admitted
that he had essentially hid the severity
of the injury from the team he hasn't
played since and now he won't play for
at least eight more weeks and that puts
us into the postseason and by then if
the panthers make it i don't know that
you want to go back to cam newton i
think the goal here is shut him down
let him heal and then in the offseason
mds a decision will have to be made
about the future of cam newton in
carolina
yeah and to me that's really the most
interesting part of all of this is
not just is kyle allen the quarterback
for the rest of this year but is kyle
allen the quarterback of the future and
the into the panthers and if he's not
that still might not mean that cam
newton is the quarterback of the future
even if kyle allen doesn't play well the
rest of the way
maybe the panthers decide to draft a
quarterback to sign a different
quarterback cam newton has one year left
on his contract at a salary that's
affordable by
uh nfl starting quarterback salaries i
mean there are plenty of teams that
could trade for him
get his salary under the salary cap in
2020 and then work on either a long-term
deal or franchise him the next year
now we're getting two years ahead so
maybe that's a little too far but it's a
really interesting question and it is in
fact possible cam newton has played his
very last game as the quarterback of the
carolina panthers
his salary for next year was downright
cheap in comparison to current starting
quarterback standards 18.6 million they
have a two million dollar cap charge for
option bonus proration a 500 000 workout
bonus so the total cash payout is 19.1
million
and if there's somebody else out there
that wants him it really is an
affordable contract and i think one of
the big factors will be
what will owner david tepper do after
the season there was a very telling
moment in the all or nothing series when
tepper explains in the last episode the
league is set up for teams to go eight
and eight and it's up to them to push it
north of that or south of that and a
franchise quarterback is key but getting
a good coach getting a good gm
is a difference maker well david tepper
didn't buy the panthers for the
privilege of employing marty herney as
gm and ron rivera's head coach he
inherited them if he decides after this
year it's time to make changes and go
out and maybe try to buy an upgrade at
either or both spots
those new
people general manager and or head coach
may want their own quarterback they may
want cam newton for one more year they
may want their own person so there's
decisions that need to be made after the
season that are going to be influenced
by how the panthers do the rest of the
season that will have a major impact mds
on whether or not cam newton is with the
team in 2020
yeah and david tepper has not owned the
panthers for long enough for us to have
a good idea of
how patient is he
with his football people is he going to
be the type of owner who believes in his
guys and gives them a long time to build
a team or is he going to be the type of
owner who says
if you don't impress me this year you're
gone next year and if it's the latter
we could see all kinds of changes in
carolina and i would also throw out
david tepper is really rich even by nfl
owner standards um the you know the
when you get into the many billions it's
sometimes hard to even wrap your head
around how rich he is but suffice to say
cash flow isn't an issue for him he
doesn't care how much is still owed on
ron rivera's contract that type of thing
he doesn't care how much he would have
to pay to maybe lure uh
one of the best coaches who some people
think are retired or a coach out of
college or whoever he thinks is the
right coach for him
he can spend the money easily
to get the right coach for him so it's
one of the most interesting situations
to monitor um he might also be a coach
who would tell his general manager
i want you to spend a lot of money on a
free agent quarterback
and your job hinges on impressing me and
so you know it'll be really interesting
to see but there are a lot of ways that
the panthers franchise could go this off
season
one last observation as it relates to
david tepper he was a minority owner of
the pittsburgh steelers and he's a
pittsburgh guy
and kevin colbert the gem of the
steelers is on essentially a
year-to-year arrangement with pittsburgh
he could leave the steelers after the
draft and join david tepper in carolina
if that's what tepper wants and
you mentioned retired coaches that are
out there bill cower has been out of the
loop for so long we don't even think of
him as a potential head coaching
candidate i think one of the reasons he
quit when he did was because he knew he
was never going to get true market value
in pittsburgh and i think his plan
initially was to eventually come back
and get whatever the most money is for
coaches in the nfl i don't know that
tepper would give him that but maybe
that's a spot where he could be lured to
come out of retirement if that's
something that tepper wants but you're
right it all comes down to what pepper
wants and he did not buy that team
because he wanted to say i have on the
payroll marty herney and ron rivera they
just happened to be there when the new
boss arrived
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports